probably bad but like you know it's four
bucks was it four blocks
he said I was the sort of a Woodward was
before it's 40 I'm 40 I was 40 bucks
away 40.
[Music]
an Oklahoma Police Captain was arrested
for a DUI
and then he was filmed asking a sergeant
to turn off his body camera during the
DUI stop oh my God you gotta ask yeah so
he he is the
um captain of the Oklahoma Police
Department homicide investigation team
he was pulled over on suspicion of drunk
driving by the captain or by Sergeant
Chris Skinner he doesn't know that
that's a captain yet right he stops him
and after allegedly seeing the captain
swerving speeding not using his turn
signals and then this happened I'm gonna
play a video for you oh dance was he
like you know who I am he goes what do
you know who I am and they just kept
doing that back you know who I am no no
you know who I am you you tell me who
you are they're doing it while slowly
backing him same time
times
you drunk huh
a what
of what the big dope reach in your
pocket get back in your car
you said I'm okay yeah cause it's like
Captain my football team
[Laughter]
I'm the Captain Crunch Captain Crunch
been drinking tonight
you've been drinking tonight sir I'm a
captain
he's like whispering
oh my God what division
investigations
what are you doing pulling in here my
mom and I stay here you've been drinking
Captain Morgan's
nice you think the cop believed him
though
[Music]
it's gone
off the camera huh
this is a joke
caught in 4k it's like a Will Ferrell
yeah we're not gonna get a return on it
how much we drink tonight sir how's the
poker game
because you're swerving all over
here you didn't use your signal to say
it again I'm sorry that's where it works
yeah
not much not much son of a [__]
[Music]
it's called not much it's a Pilsner
it's an IPA
two wire coolers
what time is it now
for one
midnight
of course you think you should drive him
no but I came from four blocks
your mom your mom lives here I live here
you live here yes
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
really yeah
like whispering to the camera I like the
whisper it's so good it's like the
closer you get to the camera the louder
you are
yeah I don't think he realizes that so
I'll skip to the highlights because it
does take a lot of skipping around right
so one part he says sir can you turn
that off I'm asking you I'm a captain at
the police department and then
um the the cop says I don't care if
you're gangbanger or president United
States which is kind of a meta little
meta joke because like Biden came and
walk up some stairs
he says if I was to treat you any
differently then I was to treat uh some
South Side local or some pedo how does
it look on me and then they both fist
bumped over that is that true
through the cops he was like yeah
that's cool you dude that's cool
he's not my captain yeah so then you
know he says I know you're aware of our
body cam policy you know I can't turn
off the body can he says I do but I'd
like to talk to you in the whispered
tone again when he whispers hey
the law I don't show favoritism to
anyone regardless knowing that he's
filmed by the way I kind of always like
that but hey we got to give him credit
for for he actually didn't turn off the
cameras well I wonder what happens after
though you know well he says are you
gonna arrest me sir and he says yes I am
and then he was booked so um okay good
but was he booked is that what you're
saying there yeah who knows dude
follow-up story no can't trust the media
where'd the book go yeah where's the
record of the book uh so yeah he was
placed on administrative leave and they
launched an internal investigation they
always do that [__] he's gonna be back
right
I hope I hope it gets promoted dude four
blocks there's nothing dude
probably bad but like you know it's four
blocks was it four blocks
he said I was those sort of a woodwork
it's 40 I'm 40 I was 40 bucks away 40.
oh 40. that's crazy how even captains
resort to the same like sad tactics it's
like regular people let me ask you this
he's obviously so maybe he's in lala
or being like the camera is like
something that happens all the [__]
time
maybe maybe I'm nuts um conspiracy Steve
set by default no yeah that's right
because there's like a bro code with
cops of course honestly if I was the guy
that was arresting this dude and he was
a captain I'd be like
you're you're one of ours let's get at
it hey you were sitting on camera you're
one of ours let's go hey let me just say
this right now next round's on me
brother
[Laughter]
and then I go home I put my camera I go
to the office the next morning I could
put the camera on my desk and I to the
boss yeah hey dude look how cool I am
and then do you think your boss is like
look I'm gonna have to write you up and
he's like why not he's like if you're
trying to build this thing he's like you
got to tell people to subscribe in the
first 30 seconds
retention retention and then you have to
try to remember you're trying to hit
these people with like you're trying to
get comments you're trying to boost
yourself in the algorithm yeah you're
right man a little too low energy at the
beginning yeah my bad I'm gonna really
bring that in early let's redo it go
back
I like when I'm watching like anything
now and then like this thing comes up on
screen and then like they make a
clicking sound like I clicked it I'm
like I didn't click it
I subscribe
so annoying it's just crazy to think
that that's even an option because he
says it's so comfortable like hey turn
it off like the fact that you can
do it but like
his real command so they don't throw out
any cases what if like a cop turns off
the body cam like that's not questions
yeah but they say that it wasn't working
what's the company they should sue the
company yeah oh are they gonna sue the
Epstein camera guys yeah because that
was a malfunctioning too bud all the
jail footage was malfunctioning
also the tapes killed themselves
the cameras are malfunctioning and the
tapes killed the guards were sleeping
did you find did you know that the
guards somehow have new homes and like
new the guards of yeah those guys have
new homes new things by the way the
tapes tweeted that they were not
suicidal and then the tapes killed
themselves
Epstein's like like hey I'm not trying
to kill myself if I die and then the
next day he died yep
I'm surprising they didn't end up like
dead or something you know the guards
well they played ball the whole time
though yeah I would play ball too
they're a very good one I'd be like yeah
I didn't see [__] I didn't see [__]
[__] man that's how I would tell
everybody I saw a dead man kill himself
making if you're making like 20 bucks an
hour right and then they go check this
out I'm gonna give you a new house I'm
Gonna Give You whatevers
buy three cars whatever you want fall
asleep but now you're on the books
forever all you gotta do is fall asleep
on this day he goes eyes fall asleep
every day yeah it's like Bernie Sanders
we'll get you we'll give you another
house
just gotta fall asleep we've rigged the
election against you for Hillary Clinton
that's all been documented Donna Brazil
wrote a book about it nobody's gonna
ever talk about it again and we'll let
you get another house so now birdie has
three houses you know some funny [__]
that just came out basically uh so the
Hillary Camp they started funding like
hardcore alt-right groups plus the Trump
campaign because she thought their Camp
thought that if Trump wins the nominee
he's the one that they can beat right oh
yeah I always thought that it was
hilarious that when Trump won he looked
like so surprised like what the [__]
serious right and he goes well I guess
and then he just started believing it
right but the thing is they've been
friends so I'm like forever they might
have just had this like deal like all
right so you're gonna I'm gonna win
right y'all okay fine and I'll just fund
your campaign we'll do this thing and
then she lost cause dude in 2020
Democrats were funding manga candidates
yeah they could run against them in the
primaries that's documented it's all out
there but he's talking about it of
course it runs counter narrative
hilarious and they're like oh but the
market candidates are Insurrection it's
like well why did they fund them why
were the Democrats helping they would
fund them finding them it's funny it's
so [__] funny I'm not cynical I love
America he's in it thick January 6th was
worth it though
[Music]
foreign